all right everybody welcome to another
or YouTube hangout super excited to be
back with my friend Stephen Kelly the
CEO of the best accounting software in
the world sage we had a month off we had
some technical difficulties or just our
scheduling issues last month but we've
got two happening in June and today
we're going to talk about how to stand
out with your customers Stephen welcome
back hey great to be here and I love
these hangouts so it's always cool
even just to be in your company 3,000
miles away Evan lights up my day I love
well I'm excited for this topic but
before that I heard just before going on
that you are starting a vlog and the
first one comes out today yeah yeah so I
just thought you know obviously sage is
a big company great technology company
largest tech company in the UK all those
good things that actually amazingly our
customers ever ah my guys told me this
manage and move money around the world
to the equivalent of about four trillion
dollars US dollars so it's like massive
he's like you know it's a good public
twice the size of the Canadian GDP gross
domestic currency um but you know we
feel like the world's most exciting and
yet the biggest startup that's the way
we think and I just thought wouldn't it
be great if everybody who's kind of one
of your followers and the folks out
there aspiring entrepreneurs grafters we
want to build a business follow their
dreams what about if I kind of gave a
day in the life of Stephen Kelley's just
ran a kind of video diary ah that we
kind of post and so that's what we
started was down the block and and
actually want to come out and meet you
or Jeff do special editions and stuff
like that
with a worm in Toronto maybe even go to
a Blue Jays gate yeah again I love that
kind of September October and Blue Jays
kick it off so um yeah no I think it'd
be interesting to see yeah one other
because it must seem I suppose you know
what it's like being an entrepreneur
from the outside seems pretty glamorous
but when you're there in the heat of the
daily battles the ups and downs
the sort of daily rollercoaster that
everybody you know on all your all your
followers experience it can feel very
different from the inside so I want to
give armed people a kind of uncut
version or what's it like to be a you
know chief executive of what see one
five hundred come after fifty company
one of the biggest companies in terms of
Technology around the world
so that's the blesser purpose and what I
should say is obviously level your
followers to pick up and look at the
vlog more we'll post it later today but
also love feedback two-way feedback so
if you guys want me to cover different
things that you don't think it's useful
whatever I really want to make sure
there's content in there that helps
people entrepreneurs um just just
overcome any fears and make good
decisions and grow their businesses and
expand very cool I'm excited to see it
the audiences are you excited we're
getting people writing in - so excited
all caps see this duo again I always
intake so much vital information so I'm
pumped to get it going now before
getting to the topic people always love
the Stephen Kelly quotes to kick us off
so we're we've been waiting for a month
what do you have for us Stephen give us
some good quotes I got some pretty cool
quotes obviously one of the legends are
around technology Apple Steve Jobs so he
Steve captures some of the essence he
says get closer than ever to your
customers so close that you can tell
them what they need well before they
realize it themselves and obviously he
did that with the iPhone and stuff like
that brilliant brilliant innovation a
music so next one another great amazing
entrepreneur at Amazon and Jeff Bezos
and you know obviously he says and he's
built incredible culture around
customers we see customers as invited
guests to our party and we are the hosts
it is our job every day to make every
important aspect of the customer
experience just a little bit better and
then this is so true and you know this
and I know this is a great work from the
the sage himself the sage Warren Buffett
um I like that I like that he is the
sage the ultimate investor sage and
anybody who doesn't know him checking
out Warren Buffett google him probably
the most legendary investor of the last
50 years ah and still incredibly strong
and he says which is great and we know
this it takes 20 years to build a
reputation and five minutes to ruin it
if you think about that then you'll do
things differently so I think kind of
three quotes to kick off from amazing
luminaries Warren Jeff Azeroth and Steve
Jobs just to kind of get it going but it
you know this customer experience and
standing out from customers is the
essence of a brilliant business where
your idea or product really builds love
from the customers point of view so it's
a great topic and it's great also ever
probably to say that you your viewers
are the guys who made this topic for us
so I hope we're going to give you in
this hangout some really fantastic
material out your businesses can really
stand up for your customers I love it
well before getting into the questions
I've already popping up in the live chat
what are your overall thoughts what are
your top line kind of overall advice big
three things that entrepreneurs need to
do to stand out with their customers I
think um you know something we've said
all along you've got to put yourselves
in the shoes of the customers you've got
to live and breathe and go where your
audience is and then you've got to do
things really intelligent around what is
the need that you're serving for your
customers what is it their need or one
and then the big thing around this topic
is how do you do it so differently that
they'll remember that for every you know
how do you make their lives so much
better and how do you differentiate
yourself build massive value massive
loyalty fanaticism we will you know we
want your customers to be fanatical for
you and feel love for your brand and
your product in your service so I think
they're the things now number one
sitting the shoes of our new customers
secondly really think about what is it
they want they
eat to be successful and then then the
big thing is and how do you stand out
how do you differentiate self why are
you different
yau theme must have product a bell
they'll rave about to their friends when
they go to a college party or whatever
I'm wondering my own personal interest
for Sage like what are you guys doing I
know I know you personally every time
you go traveling you have to go and talk
to customers you make that a priority
and go meet some local customers what
are some of the ways that sage as a
business or you personally work to try
to stand out with with your customers
yeah I'm so kind of what we think about
is everything actually from the planning
process for the company through to the
daily activity always says you know what
what is it for the customer where is the
customer in this conversation
um and it's so easier I'd say this is so
easy for big companies to start kind of
becoming sort of navel-gazing internally
focused whatever were to use like
analysis paralysis
um and it's easy for particularly you
everybody will know this if you've been
in a big company there's some people who
get a bit complacent a bit comfortable
and and what you need you as the
entrepreneurs is to always have that
kind of shock therapy where everything
is always about the customer and
sometimes in the extreme you know and I
do it here little symbolic things like
if we're on the internal meeting with
marketing and product development I'll
keep a chair free for the customer I'll
turn around I'll say you know here's a
customer they're in a plumbing business
or they're in a digital marketing agency
and they're fast growing you know what
what are the things they're going to be
worried about and we can really address
in this conversation and then I think
the other thing as you've scale and grow
your businesses all the entrepreneurs
out there and you hire your tenth
employer in 15 or 20 you want to inject
that everything you build is has to be
centered around the customers you serve
and even things like in the recruitment
process make that explicit when they
join you know you do some sort of
onboarding
you know induction whatever you want to
call it and again make sure is explicit
around the value drives your customers
and why you're different so they kind of
get it because what you want you know
it's really this kind of mother an
apple-pie to see so Evan you want your
colleagues the people work in your
company to be the biggest advocates and
the biggest ambassadors for your product
because you want to tell your friends
that you're a great business you got
amazing vision you got a great idea
you're going to change the world because
you want them to attract their friends
and you know recruit more people and
more customers and partners so I think
um what the essence is the question
Evan is everything you do kind of from
getting that first thing in the morning
to kind of going to bed everything with
a planning strategic everything's got to
be centered on the customer ah and
ultimately provide a massive
differentiation and value to the
customer on a sustainable basis for them
to be successful I love it eleven
jumping some wisdom bombs right off the
start first questions coming in from J
rise is asking about your blog so I it's
it's not a blog it's a vlog right it's a
video
you didn't videos right and you want to
do with not ages it's just going to be
on your it's going to be on the sage
YouTube channel
yeah and I'll post it on all the
channels you know obviously things like
Twitter as well so I'll post that so if
you guys are following me it should be
on the on the kind of screen but um s
Kelly CEO um then you know you'll you'll
kind of get it coming out today I'll
post it and I'll post it to all my
channels as well Instagram Facebook and
also Twitter and stuff like that so
they'd be good and it's video because I
I add this isn't right so this is kind
of related topic we think video uh and
actually the channel of YouTube is
unbelievable for you guys to really
market and sell your products and your
brand and why you're different and we
think video is just an amazing way
people consume technology choices ideas
and all these other things and and this
is kind of a
aggression actually but it's kind of
interesting Evan I think you were there
we had our Chad Hurley who was the
co-founder and CEO of YouTube when it
started yeah um and I was sitting them
in the safe summit back in I think it's
New Orleans ah and we talked to Chad
about his dream for YouTube I think at
the time he said well we would have been
blown away if we'd had like 20,000 sort
of YouTube subscribers and we thought if
people could post hundreds of video
pieces a day that'd be incredible and
that would have been success and I think
I've read something like you know even
six months ago there's like 400 hours of
content being posted every minute so I
we just think the the level of
consumption by both consumers and
actually business people around video
content is great and it's so so this
vlog my mission is are kind of do it
probably initially every two weeks and
it's no more than I like five or six
seven minutes it says very easy to
consume and we'll probably will probably
have to make sure when we have a special
moment Evan we capture it on the vlog
you know I'm excited and for those of
you guys watching I've been talking
about - I've been talking to Steven
about video for a while I remember way
back on one of our first hangouts one of
our audience members couldn't make it
because they were doing cancer treatment
and Steven ended up at the airport
making a quick little video on his
phones wishing that person good luck and
hope the treatment goes well and we'll
see you hopefully at the next episode it
was a really cool thing to do for you I
got this CEO got 13 14 15 thousand
employees and taking the time out of his
day to make a custom video and so I'm I
think it could do really well on the
vlog and I'm excited that that's coming
out um okay let's get to some questions
they've been piling up if we as we've
been talking the first is from shariq
who's asking how do you surround
yourself with great people who care
about the customers um that's a great
question you know what one of the things
you can do in the early days is probably
hire and your company it cost
um or someone who lives and walks and
breathes the customer journey every day
and in you know a lot of us the other
things we kind of do which i think is
pretty cool is how things are
entrepreneurs in residence so we have
you like Nicole Hardin is who come in to
Sage to work for us and they're
entrepreneurs they're you know they've
graphed as they started their business
then they walked in the shoes they're
done maybe three or four businesses
where they've done startups and grow
them up done an exit going on to the
next one so I think the other thing you
know is in reality uh loads of things
but we sort of touched on is make sure
you is the entrepreneur and the foul
mother talk always about customers and
you all very much buy that you would
attract similar individuals who really
care passionately about customers and
then the other thing I think it's a
really good idea if it's achievable is
you actually join the communities of
your customers and you can do that on
social media but also I'd always
advocate if you can without you know
without kind of cross the line in terms
of upsetting customers if you can
recruit customers into your business who
understand you know obviously the
customer perspective but also understand
how the scale and grow your business as
well that's a fantastic lens for you to
have within your company that's
interesting I have you guys I'm curious
what you guys deal with customers so you
have some of them who sit in on board
meetings or who advise you guys or have
you hired them away from their business
and now they're working inside sage and
different projects yeah we've got a
number of things actually I think you've
met some of these guys we've got this
sage ambassadors program so we've got
business experts so we and I go along
for myself of the every month they meet
up country by country and meet the local
management team a sage talk about issues
relevant to you know the customer
journey ah
and also I tend to check in with those
guys and the other things we do is have
this kind of concept of entrepreneurs in
residence where they come in kind of
help us understand more about what what
are the pain points and gain points our
customers see and then also
yeah we have taken on some folks I
mentioned Nicole there's a few folks a
lot of folks actually in the company who
have been entrepreneurs themselves and
come to work for sage because there's no
better perspective than having having
kind of done it and worn the t-shirt and
started a couple of companies you know
and also ever not only companies that
have been successful but some of the
best learnings you get is when you you
hit the kind of skids and you you have a
failure and you have to exit prematurely
or you know you don't realize your
dreams because inevitably the reality is
this fantastic in the US there's our
millions of businesses start every year
over in the UK there's about 600,000 new
business started last year but within
five years probably 60% of those would
have felt I don't like that word failure
because if you fail and you fail fast
that's probably the best learners you're
ever going to get as an entrepreneur and
you can go on and create a fantastically
successful business next time I love it
in thinking about attracting a great
team I would say to that when you stand
for something it's easy to get the right
people on board it was really clear and
all your messaging and all your
activities that you care about the
customer you're going to attract people
who care about the customers you know if
people are applying to Sage and they see
Stephen on his vlog interact with
customers and continue to care about
them then the people who like that are
gonna be the ones who also believe in
the same thing and so if you're really
clear about your mission what you stand
for what you're here to do and if
serving customer needs is your mission
then you're going to attract people who
want to be a part of that if it's
unclear what you stand for then if
you're hiring a programmer or customer
service representative or whoever into
your business you're going to get all
all kinds of different people and so you
want to be really upfront clear what
your mission is you attract like-minded
people and the people who don't agree
with your mission they're never going to
apply so they self eliminate from the
start great let's get to some more so -
is writing in how would you suggest
being successful with limited resources
do you believe in your character
personality and/or values driving the
business as opposed to the equipment you
own yeah - has a great
question that I think would probably
also say it's all about leadership it's
your personality you are the expression
of the idea or the product you sell and
I think we talked about the integrity
that you have the love and the dream and
the inspiration and the vision that you
can not only as far your customers may
be partners but also people who were few
in the business colleagues that's really
really fundamental and the personality
is really important so I think that
there's a lot of things you as a leader
when you want to stand out it's so easy
to be swayed by a lot of people and I
think if you have a really strong
conviction into Evans point you know
hashtag believe then how do you stand
out from the crowd you know we stand in
the shoes of the customer you've got a
big idea so I think there's a whole
theme around you know obviously you want
to listen to the colleagues you want to
listen to the market really carefully
but you also got to be confident and be
decisive and make those calls and then
kind of put a lot of the wood behind a
few arrows and really focus on being
successful
and I'd always encourage you to be have
that beginner's mind you know be
different think differently think about
the next thing what we want is it for
especially in the world of
disintermediation customers will in five
years time be doing that you can invent
today so do you think differently and I
think a lot of that comes from you know
as you said it's your personality and
make make your brand very visible in
terms of your personality in your
leadership because that will inspire all
the important people like customers and
especially your colleagues if you get
those two right you've got a fantastic
business what was the analogy you used
to focus on the wood behind your few
arrows how what you said oh yeah yes so
so I this is a cutter this is cream this
is not a metaphor for the digital age
but you know it's just it when you you
know when you're an entrepreneur one of
the biggest problems you have is
prioritization hey this is really
interesting prioritize I think it comes
from a Greek word and you know how we
say what are your top four branches well
that actually breaches the essence of
the gray
word prioritize means you can only do
one thing uno one thing no more you
can't do two priorities free presto is
so it's ruthless and obviously in the
modern age we have lots of priorities
the biggest challenge we have as
entrepreneurs is that single focus
around the thing that's really going to
move the needle move the dot and so we
have this phrases you know you can have
50 arrows out there go to 50 markets and
try and do 50 different things or
generate them and create 14 different
products we'd say no no no have a big
vision but then day to day for the first
90 days put all the wood behind one
arrow one arrow as in two bows and
arrows and all that sort of stuff yeah
all the wood on those arrows so you put
huge critical mass and then create a
beachhead where you've got momentum you
got fanatical customers and then you use
this that love to actually go on to the
next beachhead and then the next
beachhead and then makes it trying to
you know honestly my experience of
entrepreneurs we are so optimistic we
are so excited we are so into our idea
and yet sometimes we just got to check
ourselves and instead of trying to be
all things to all people
we should be brilliant at one thing at a
time and then that can build a great
company I like it I've never heard that
expression before so I like it it's good
it's good extra ammunition to play with
there to the question of limited
resources I mean that's that's
entrepreneurship you never have all the
resources that you need that that's
that's why you go out and create
something new and innovative because
you're forced up against the wall to
find another way to stand I think what
really helped me when I was getting
started was recognizing that people that
I looked up to the people that I aspire
to you know have that kind of impact on
some of the people behind me on the wall
they started with less than what I
already have right now you know the
people who you look up to and you want
to be like you know the Titans in your
industry look at their story and look at
how they started chances are it wasn't
just handed to them and they started off
with less than what you already have
right now and so I use that as as
motivation to save these guys could do
it I can do it too
you and instead of seeing limited
resources as as a complaining point
users your opportunity that's that's
where you have a chance to do something
different and stand out that's the game
that's entrepreneurship you will have
limited present you got to use them
wisely put the wood behind the few error
hey you're gonna love this everything
you're gonna love this again so one
thing I've talked a lot about here is
and you'll love this you'll have this
quote the answer is never more resources
the answer is always more resourceful
nurse and that's why I'm to preneur is
hugely successful they always overcome
difficulties there are never any excuses
they always touch the stars
I think we got to save that quote for
next time you leave us off with it
that's a good on yeah it reminds me of
Steve Wozniak who co-founded Apple who
who said stop thinking about the
resources that you don't have and
instead think about what you can do with
what you do have and I think once you
change your mindset from just being you
know complaining or desperate or you
know upset to a positive one okay I have
something here let's use what I have to
build it that's when you start becoming
more successful so I like it um next
Randy is writing in hi Steven it's Randy
I own a resort on an island should I act
on all the feedback from my customers
and should I encourage feedback yeah I
think Randy if you own a resort you need
to kind of ping ever than me and invite
but we love that so you know I let me
gum just just thinking of what people
like obviously people that TripAdvisor
but there's just tons of social sites
where everything is about reviews and
obviously now what - like Airbnb
Abdullah was sort of guys I think yeah
you you're in a super almost transparent
marketplace and that's obviously fueled
by social media so I think you know just
looking at consuming the data point is
like 70% of people now kind of book
resorts and stuff online you know the
old kind of model over going through
things like travel agents and stuff is
pretty redundant
and the really important thing is this
is where and this is so important you
know customer love how do you inspire
customer love in terms of resort and I
think a message to entrepreneurs I'd
always give is if you can just do every
little thing every little interaction
like the book in the reservation the
Welcome you know the room the breakfast
whatever it is you do when you break
down the whole journey for a customer
and break it down to every component
every touch point every moment of their
day if you just exceed their
expectations just by a little bit then
you will be remembered forever by that
individual and I think the other thing
we forget it's like a resort
vacation is wow you know if it goes well
typically you don't get a level of
fanaticism
if it goes exceptionally well they'll
tell maybe five people if it goes badly
they'll tell a hundred people so um the
cards are stacked against you on the
downside if you get it wrong now I would
say also I think um authenticity is
really important and I get I'm customs
we got we got our well three million
customers businesses around the world
use our technology till we get it right
every day of the week every second
absolutely not do we drop the ball yeah
and when we do that I'll get customers
diem and me um emailing me calling me
and I'll say wow you know my aspiration
is that we have the happiest and most
delighted and rated fanatical are
incredibly advocates out there but we
drop the ball you know sometimes the
proxy doesn't work or the internet that
were connecting all the clouds went down
whatever there's some stuff just stuff
happens so what I do in those situations
and you could really do this powerfully
in a result when stuff goes wrong you
know the visibility of you Randy as the
leader picking up a phone call them on
their cell phone at that moment having
like a rapid response team sawing it out
making them whole and you know you might
get a bowl of fruit delivered to their
room or
whatever it is is very powerful and then
the other thing I'd say is because when
they go back and they come back to say
Toronto or Vancouver or Minneapolis two
weeks later you know how it is on
vacation this is interesting when you
have a vacation you have the best time
the world and you talk about dreams and
all that sort of stuff and you have
really sort of Easter terror
conversations with your palm of your
friends when you get back within six
hours of getting back you feel like you
haven't had a vacation do you have that
feeling like wow I've just been away for
two weeks in Hawaii and I'm back here
and wow just um my emails my inbox I'm
overwhelmed it's crazy I can't see the
wood from the trees and it feels like I
have that vacation at all
now how powerful would it be Randy if
two weeks after that person's vacation
on your resort when something went wrong
they got a bouquet of flowers just
saying we're really sorry we drop the
ball we hope you had an amazing time
because they'd remember you forever and
they would be your advocates because
because it is just about those little
moments of magic that you create where
you give them an experience that plays
their brain I love it that extra love I
love it um so Randy is from Trinidad the
islands I'm Trinidad and he's writing in
that he's writing all of this stuff down
he's love when you advise uh Randy I
would say I would split into two things
one there's the algorithmic marketing
side of things with your Google reviews
and your TripAdvisor and Expedia reviews
and all of the new game that you have to
play because when people are booking
they want to see the you have positive
reviews so yes incentivizing your
customers to leave reviews and share
their honest opinions that will help you
with new marketing but on the other side
is just providing a great experience to
everything Steve's been talking about I
would study Steve Wynn I would study the
Four Seasons Hotel the classic story of
you know somebody left their bags at
your hotel and they went to the airport
and the bellhop gets the bags and
follows them in the cab and delivers
them at the airport to them right like
just looking for extra ways if somebody
asks for directions to the pool don't
just tell them take them to the pool and
show them every little touch point
everything Steven was saying to try to
make it a memorable experience
means to turn that one off I'm going to
go to Trinidad and check out this new
resort versus every winter I'm going to
this resort in Trinidad and I'm bringing
my whole family with me because these
guys get it and have the best service so
if you give that give them that amazing
experience you're gonna want to come
back every year tell their friends about
it as well yeah but are these right to
the subject you know how do you stand
out I think this is a great area where
Randy especially if you're ensuring that
beautiful island trim them to bago
I love the Caribbean you can really sit
down and think about based on all the
reviews number one is kind of any
entrepreneur will say well what market
am I going for where is the audience and
I think this is where you can be really
honest so maybe either maybe your market
is twenty to thirty year olds
maybe it's travelers maybe it's families
so um where these kind of particularly
resorts get it wrong is when they start
mixing up the audience's so you get
young families and then you get party
animals and 25 year olds going on Spring
Break parties that's going to be a
disaster because no one's going to be
happy because the guys who want to go
out all night and drink all night and
party all night will be waking up all
the fans so you need to really say what
is the market I'm serving who is the
segment is it families is it what
generation what nationality you know you
can get really granular and then I think
people really appreciate honesty as well
so on your website you should say look
if you're a young family you're probably
not going to have a great experience
here because this is a party resort yeah
but if you're 18 to 30 years old and you
want to have the best time of your life
this is the result for you and then you
really meet the market and everything's
you know still bands when they get to
resolve you know all the kind of great
music that comes from the Caribbean or
all the fantastic stuff cocktails on the
beach rum punches all that sort of stuff
swear you're very much differentiating
yourself making yourself different from
the kind of big brands so you can create
a unique experience for your customers
to really meet their needs and once
ah and you know they go away feeling
like they've been sitting with Bob
Marley for two weeks and experiencing
the real Caribbean so I think you can do
that and then I would advocate really to
what haven't said even more that you
want to get that social listening and
actually on this area there's some
brilliant social listening tools you can
get where not only do people write
reviews but there's stuff you don't see
that they write in other places where
you can get a pulse of what's going on
and I'd absolutely say that and if
there's stuff out there the best thing
you can do as an entrepreneur is know
about it yourself the worst thing you
can have happen to you is for someone to
denigrate your brand or your product or
your resort and not tell you about it if
if they tell you about it you got you
got every opportunity to fix it and it's
and with these things you know this as
consumers when you fix stuff for
customers when they go wrong that's when
you see great companies great companies
always will make mistakes but when great
companies make mistakes they step up
tool they stand shoulder to shoulder
with a customer and they fix it and make
the customer whole I love it Paula and
Peter we're coming to you guys next but
I just have a follow-up question for
Stephen
I agree with everything you say you're
gonna have some people thinking okay
even though I get most my business from
the party crowd I don't want to lose the
families because my place isn't full and
so I don't want to turn away business
what do you what do you say how do you
respond to that reaction I think the
beauty of the beauty of a resort type
business you know this the economics is
all about utilization and then it's once
you've got the utilization that probably
covers your cost and then the
profitability you make is is through
kind of food beverage all those sort of
things so there's a number of options
you have in resolve is I wouldn't claim
to be an expert but you can look at kind
of times of the year you could have the
same resort like in vacations of you
know like Christmas vacation all
families and then you could say right
now kind of win mid-january on to kind
of middle of February you could
just say it's going to be part of resort
and you could actually change the spaces
in the areas to accommodate your your
audience my what I would say is you kind
of don't want to mix up in the same
locality different people with different
needs and different um you know and it's
all the case you know Evans got kids
I've got kids what I wanted to do when I
was 21 was very different when I when I
was 35 with kids so I think the other
thing if you've got a big Resort then
you could have a latitude to have
different spaces for different audiences
um and it kept coming comes back to
really what is the audience you're
serving what is the segment and then how
do you leverage your property you resort
to do that best and then also look at
the times of the year you know you'll
get very different people coming to the
Caribbean during hurricane season then
you will do you know in that kind of
January February March period um so I
think it could be different and the
other thing actually Evan this is
different when you have a load of
results do this when you have off-peak
times and I think you're right you need
you need the utilization you need the
occupancy then you can probably target
specialist interest groups so you could
do yoga weeks or you could do Pilates
and you could have a completely
different audience and make sure that
the kind of the results kitted out for
that but but that's a great way in low
occupancy and in bad offseason times to
keep the occupancy up with different
communities but it all comes back to who
you serve and what's the audience need
what are that where do they what do they
want and how do you Excel it yeah I
think sometimes you just have to turn
away the wrong customer if it's not a
fit for you you know I give all sage had
was sage one which is the kind of
entry-level
package you're not going to go to IBM
and say hey buy our sage once-off which
is not a fit it's not going to be a
great experience for anybody and so yes
it might bring short-term revenue into
your business but there's going to be
complaints you're going to get negative
scores everywhere it's going to be a
hassle for your staff all your customers
going to be unsatisfied with it and so
if you understand who your ideal target
market is and just go strong after them
and give them the best possible
experience that means to the stevens
point about prior
Pisan and the Greek word and coming down
to one thing
you know means that some customers are
not going to be perfect fits for your
business and that's okay
because if you try to appeal to
everybody it means you're going to
strongly appeal to nobody let's hit up
Paula Paula I have a question
exclamation point
when your client portfolio grows to a
point where you realize that you need
help what tasks do you believe are
critical for you to continue handling
yourself so she's struggling to kind of
grow it's a good place to be
congratulations Paula she's going to
climb up fully to a certain size and she
needs help what you should be looking
for and how she how should she be
spending her time yeah I think it's
great question Paula and obviously Paula
congratulations only growth of your
business so it's fantastic I'd say
things that really matter is things that
touch the customer so um and typically
you'll find poorly you'll know you kind
of really customer into the customer
experience sales marketing type person
or are you like product genius like a
Steve Jobs where you you really have the
ideas you really find the same person
with both kind of sets of kind of skills
so you may surround yourself you
typically have you know partnerships die
than where you've got someone who's very
externally focused and someone who does
either all the kind of back office all
the the inventor what I would say is the
first areas you should look to bring in
other folks which should be very easy to
automate is things like what we call the
back-office finance paying your taxes
and obviously you know we've got a great
network of people like accountants and
bookkeepers who can help you with that
and you typically pay them a retainer or
an annual fee and they do all the kind
of billing invoicing cash collection all
those sort of things to make sure you've
got great cash flow in your business the
other things that then you can start
thinking about is on some of the really
specialist areas which are really cool
and do give you big differentiation and
I'll pick out one area like that is
digital marketing you know there are
genius rockstars and there
some agencies who have got genius rock
stars who can do amazing stuff around
you know SEO optimization search engine
optimization all these sort of things
social listening social media
but that's a great area where you can be
involved overseer set the direction set
the milestones and all that stuff but
bringing external people but I would
think the thing you have to keep hold of
Paula is the essence of the customer and
and keeping that customer absolutely I
wouldn't advocate that you outsource or
bring in third parties to do that
because that's going to be always
critical to you having that customer
experience and the advocacy that you can
get okay I think if you're looking at
building on a team it's an exciting part
present entrepreneur
the first thing I'd actually do is
before looking at hiring somebody I
would look at what are the tasks that
I'm great at and where do I want to
spend most of my time that I am genius
level talent at and that's where I need
to spend as much time as I can and then
bring people on to support it but even
before hiring I would look at can i
aughtta mate some of the things in my
business like it's insane how many
people still use Excel to do their
accounting like just get accounting
software is gonna save so much time and
that sounds self-serving doing what
we're doing here but it's 100% true like
a lot of the tasks that you're doing
should just be automated and not given
to somebody when you are then going to
bring somebody on you've identified the
tasks that need to get done in the
business I can't be automated it has to
go to a person but it shouldn't be you
because you want to spend your time
doing these higher-level things those
tasks are what you want to delegate and
then when you bring them on you have to
understand that now you're a leader
you're managing a human being it's not
just this happens to so many
entrepreneurs I hire the wrong person
because it's not a good values fit as
well you think okay I bring this for
someone they're gonna save all this time
for me I'm going to offload all my work
to them and then you don't guide them
and you don't make time for them you
know the first month of working with
them is going to take a lot of your time
to train them and manage them and
understand them and guide them and so
recognizing that your role is now going
to be a leader and helping that person
reach their potential much more than
just them
accomplishing them tasks that will save
you time is super super important how
much other things board yeah no go for
it just hey just sorry sorry I've just
done two other things really is I'd
always advocated especially when you
start early stage of a company that you
kind of bring in if you're some
marketing individual or someone help
with automation cash flow books and all
that sort of stuff
you trying maybe it's one one day every
two weeks so you don't kind of jump into
it with both feet and the other thing
I'd always say is it's a really cool
thing if you're going to look at someone
on sales marketing for your business
it'd be a really good thing to we call
them interim so bring someone in on an
interim contract for three months and if
they work out to be really good then
make them permanent so you can have
these sort of inter into permanent roles
and you know just a concept there is try
before you buy so Evans right when you
bring someone new you want them to
express the essence as if they were you
Porter and that's very powerful and live
your values all those sort of things and
a great way the only way to find that
you can't do that to interviews and so
for references it's ready it's hard and
recruitment you know this when you kind
of start a company you hire first five
people you don't probably get it right
all the time
and it really slows you down you can
kind of cost yourself twelve months on
these sort of things so a pretty cool
way of doing it is sort of try before
you buy or from you know even two-week
trial period and then you do find out
when you give them some real work to do
if they share your values and show you
dreams and can deliver the acceleration
you want and expand your business I love
it what is that what is the onboarding
process look like it's aged like
somebody's been hired you've got the job
interview process okay d1 in terms of
training and introduce into the team and
getting involved what does onboarding
look like for you so it's kind of is
sort of free everybody gets to one day
so all colleagues come in and get one
there and they either get flown up to
Atlanta or big hubs are in the UK sort
of where we get everybody together
typically on the first Monday of every
month
and that's a one day and that's about
the history of the company what we care
about in terms of our customers a bit of
other products and then a lot of them
culture values and you know where to go
sort of things so they find it ah
when they leave that they should be able
to navigate around the company in there
where people are and what we really care
about around customers I'm then for
managers they get three days and they
get things like this development and all
that sort of stuff as part of that and
then for salespeople and prod people
they typically get five days so we have
a I'll be honest Evan it's an area where
I think we could do a lot better I think
if we have this conversation in three
years time you probably find in Sage
we'd want to invest
probably three days for our colleagues
joining at that stage because I think
you know pull of the other things it was
so easy to hire someone you get them a
coffee you say there you go is a laptop
and off you go
I would absolutely beg you to invest at
least a minimum morning tell them about
what your beliefs are your ideas your
values what do you want to do with
customers where you ride it you know and
then and then break all that down it's
set and in the next 30 days I think we
have to do these things and then it's 90
days you have to so they're very much
sort of results around what matters for
customers but it is work just taking
that time out even though it's crazy and
it's busy just to really onboard them
and get them aligned with your way of
thinking I love it all right next Peter
hey evidence Stephen what technology or
programs would you recommend to stand
out from the rest in customer service
while Peter this is um so I think around
customer service there's some companies
do do this Tilly pretty badly to that
the people who have done this badly and
they've invested billions in is
typically banking and financial services
so the u.s. data and arm
I think same with European data only 38%
of banks customers feel that they're
valued or rewarded for their customer so
that's that's the bad situation and and
they took to Evans point around
resourcefulness and they've spent
billions now what I would say on the
positive is there some
really cool technologies I've talked
about social listening there's some
really amazing startup companies
actually a few that we've used
internally around taking the pulse of
customers and you could do what I've
advocated future is all about taking the
pulse at every interaction and you know
customers are more and more used to this
and when you kind of build your system
and customer journey it's really
important at every stage that you try
and exceed their expectations so it's
kind of not on one hip you know one size
fits all it is a very much a journey and
I think there's there's ten odds a
achieve company we've been using rant
and rave could name that rant and rave
is a company where they do pulsing of
customers and real-time feedback and
also all the kind of score and of we use
methodology internally you know it's a
big step forward but it's not the end
game it's called Net Promoter scores and
people call it MPs and it's really
simple it's basically would you
recommend this to your friends and other
people in in your car and if they're
there are the advocates and they'd
recommend it or they're neutral or the
detractors says it's quite a pretty
simple measure and you know I think the
simplicity and the beauty of these sort
of tools are when they actually grab the
sentiment at every stage of the journey
and when they make it really simple that
you can have actionable content that you
can deliver on and therefore obviously
you know Peter that the value you get is
when you can change your process or how
you handle a customer situation how they
take product how they have you know
could be anything could be the packaging
on the product it could be any aspects
of the experience that matters to them
but it's really useful for us as
entrepreneurs to know how do we change
it how we improve it and then also test
drive it with the new prototype arm and
then also get new feedback I like it I
think to add to it I would say Allah
the from a technology perspective a lot
of the interactions are even behind the
scenes you know things like making your
website faster so I have a better
experience visiting it things like does
it take me 25 steps to buy your product
or get in touch with you likes a lot of
the stuff that just people want it
automated you want to see them time to
look through all your processes and
think can I make this better I would
also say at the Corbett at some point
there's going to be an interaction with
a human being like you can only automate
so much when somebody has a problem or
somebody wants a thank you or somebody
has a question they want to be able to
reach a human being and you know
personally for me it drives me nuts when
I have to call in to a helpline and then
it's like press one of these five
options and then one of these two
options and one of that's like your your
cycled through this 20 step process
before to get the time to human being
and so I would just look at what can I
do to make the human interaction better
and sometimes the answers just get more
people as opposed to scale the
technology like I look at my youtube
channel as an example we get hundreds of
comments every day and I want everybody
to get a response and I don't want an
automated response goes to everybody
says thank you for commenting thank you
for comment and I want a human being to
respond and so I've hired two people on
my team and that's their job as they go
through the comments every day and they
respond to everybody and they save the
ones that I need to see for me as well
because I don't have the time to go
through it's like two people's full-time
job and so sometimes the answer is just
scaling people as well and the
technology you bring on should be to
make the jobs of your people easier to
be able to have those interactions so
even a question for you is with those
two gods you brought on is how do you
get them to answer the questions as if
they were ever are you invest in them
when they joined those what would how do
you sit them down and say this is my
philosophy and what did you do about it
so my hiring process already eliminates
most of the people who wouldn't be a fit
you know it'll start off with I'm
looking for a customer service rep who
believes in entrepreneurs and the first
two paragraphs should all be about the
mission and some people look at that see
that's the stupidest thing ever it's
like great like we're not going to get
along this is not going to be a good fit
you know please don't apply because
we're going to both be wasting our time
and so a lot of the non-believers
already kind of filtered out from there
I just look good you obviously be able
to understand the context you know
English language writing properly all
that kind of stuff but I don't have them
respond as me they always put their name
at the end I don't want people thinking
that I'm responding when it's not me and
so they always put their name at the end
but but they they believe and believe
they believe in the mission they don't
always say it the same way that I would
say oftentimes they're a lot nicer than
I would be to somebody who's who's
leaving a comment and so I want them to
be themselves would still believe in a
mission I think if you if you turn
people into robots and they're going to
act like robots where I want people to
kind of believe in what I believe and
then use their judgment and their heart
to solve it as they would solve it and
it's always worked out and then they
save the ones that I need to see
suggestions for the channel complaints
about something that I did that you know
is good feedback for me to be able to
apply and learn from that's really good
and I think that's really authentic as
well Evan the other thing for Peter is
if it's like a product that you have
then I absolutely advocate within your
early customers you create some sort of
early adopter program and and this is a
program where you directly get your
customers like Evan set on the website
it's so easy when we have an idea you
know we might not be amazing website
designers but but you could have put
yourself in the shoes of the customer so
what better way to do that then have an
early adopter program where you're
getting customers to give you real-time
feedback maybe with Skype on what
experience they're getting on the
website and you just take them through
it and there's loads of ways you can
reward them for that and it makes your
customers feel really special so I would
constantly innovate your product through
and your customer service obviously
through getting direct customer
sentiment and feeling real-time through
some sort of structured sort of early
adopter program that the customers
typically I found love to be involved in
I love it next up is joy sometimes it's
hard to keep up with all the
different customer questions how do you
know how to prioritize
that's a great question joy and I think
you've got a there's probably two
categories there's stuff where it's just
two one-line answer and it you know
actually what I find particularly when
things get crazy and the volumes just go
spiked some some entrepreneurs and this
is quite naturally human can just freeze
anything on my you know Ong how do i how
do I handle this stuff
and typically I yeah we use JD I just do
it so so there's some stuff you probably
need 50 or even 80 percent you can just
carve them out and just say one-line
respond boom that is put a bit um and it
takes a lot of the noise out of it and
then I think there's kind of two
categories there's one category and it's
almost like a sort of two dimensional
chart where you've got something that's
really important and the other dimension
is urgency timeliness and urgency and I
think as entrepreneurs we often often
spend a lot of time on non important
stuff that seems to be urgent and what
we should do is really prioritize the
really important stuff so is it a new
customer that's going to drive more
revenue or beer big you know maybe it's
a rockstar customer who's going to be a
big reference who's a poster child in
their industry Wow
if that's the case that's really
important and then you need to determine
once you've determined the level of
importance of message nanosecond
decision it takes two seconds is
literally they're in on the level of
urgency and then prioritize it according
to the most important most urgent and
they could the important stuff but it
might not be time critical for today and
you can do that in 30 60 90 days so so I
just apply that sort of lends to the the
inbound to give you the clarity of the
prioritization I like it I would add if
you're getting overwhelmed by how many
emails are coming in I would look at is
my process okay like can I just make my
website more clear so I don't get as
many people don't have because people
wanna write in with a question they
don't want to write in asking for help
so can you make your process better
because for every one person who does
write n there's another 10 who just
don't bother they don't want to spend
the time and so if you make your process
better then you won't have to deal with
as much in Bound I think to then handle
the rest of them you know you have to
identify what your priorities are as a
company here's what we want to grow and
here's how it fits in and if you're
getting asked the same thing over and
over and over and over again hey maybe
that's an indication that this is you
know a new thing we should add
I'm sure it's sage people write in all
the time and say hey be great that this
feature and this feature and we'd love
to see this and can you include you know
everybody has their opinions on how you
should run your company you know in
their own best interest of course I
think collecting that feedback is
important obviously sage is not going to
include every single feature that
everybody has on their minds
but if you get the same thing coming
over and over again that can help
prioritize and say hey like a good
percentage of our customers are asking
this question is how do we pick the
topics for these sessions right like a
number of you have similar kind of
topics suggestions in mind and so the
one that is kind of most popular so we
go with for the next one I think too
though also just the people who just
letting people know where they're at
letting people know what the realistic
chances of that happening are I just
having some empathy for them you know if
for people who want my letting my
channels translated into Spanish you
know something we get asked all the time
it's something that's on my radar but
it's not an immediate priority for me
and so I write back to say thank you so
much for the love and I would love to
really create this content for you in
Spanish that you could understand it
better and grow your business in
whatever country you're in it's just not
at the top of my priority list yet but
the fact that you brought it up
you know just I'm going to remember it
and hopefully when they will get to it
just recognizing them as opposed to them
feeling like they're totally lost even
if they're never going to get the thing
that you you know that they're asking
for I think is important and I think
that's a way to stand out back to the
kind of the topic we're covering today
standing out with your customers I think
it's really important there must be tons
of people who write into sage saying
like nur this feature in this feature
tens of thousands and and without we
have sort of formal process and it's
kind of this recording basically before
I market ISM management anybody and we
love it we've actually I'll advocate I
think Evan and I the more feedback we
get from customers the better
I'm good bad indifferent whatever it is
feedback is is is is golden nuggets is
some it's absolutely magical so I you
know I'd absolutely advocating I think
with social media social and tonight is
brilliant ways to get feedback now and
and then you've got to act on it and you
do you're right you're absolutely right
Julie you've got to prioritize it and I
think Joe Evans point people just value
the honesty if you say you know that's
important but we can't do that for the
next year or so they appreciate that and
then the important thing is to put a
process in to say a little reminder on
you Google calendar or whatever in a
year's time further back say we're ready
to do it now or actually some other six
months away people just like to be kept
in touch I love it so speaking of
feedback you're launching your vlog
later on today yeah well we'll lick it
up cuz it's not live yet but when it
goes live we'll link up in the
description what kind of feedback do you
want from people on watching your first
episode of the Stephen Kelly vlog yeah I
think I'm too - my purpose is to twofold
one is to make it useful for the
audience um so you know you can very
quickly guys out there just tell me is
this useful or not and secondly I want
you to enjoy it
um I want you to have fun and watch it
and enjoy it and think oh this is five
minutes of my time this yeah it's good
fun I like it and I got kind of just one
nugget or one idea out of it that's
great so usefulness and enjoyment is
important and what we'll do is just
thinking about the seven is when we're
in Toronto in actually at Sage summit at
the back end of June I don't know if the
guys are working on this but we should
do some fun stuff me and you full of
love we should do some I'm making up the
CN n tower do some stuff there that we
could do that it's fun and also
showcases your great city as well we
love that
I'm excited I'm always down for that so
we're out of hours crazy how quickly it
goes guys the next time we're coming to
you live it'll be together me and
Stephen at the end of June so that'll be
fun even kind of final words to wrap
this up and put a bow on it for the
audience yeah I just think something
that pulls all together this is totally
random how this has happened but one of
our customers our kitty Mary who's the
founder of refuge coffee company um
she's given us quote where this sort of
says it all um we believe in doing
things that matter with people instead
of for them when you do things for
people you affirm their inherent dignity
and value you bring them into the
decision-making table and you make them
feel very part of it and that's why we
do things with our customers always with
I like it you you might be starting the
trend of now having to end every show
with a quote as well as start steering
people are gonna like those well thank
you guys stand out you go they have and
I've really enjoyed it you keep standing
out everybody there thank you guys for
watching we'll see you at the end of
June continue to believe and thank you
for tuning in to watch Rachel thanks I
love that too